الكرملين من جانبه اعرب عن قلق موسكو
الشديد اذا احدثته سقوط الصاروخ الاوكراني
في بيلاروسيا وقال الناطق باسم الكريم
لندمتري بسكوف في تصريحاته صحفيه انا قوات
البلدين على اتصال دائما ويتم التنسيق
بينهما باستمرار بما يتيح امكانيه التبادل
السريع للمعلومات الاكثر حساسيه واضاف
مسكوفنا بلا روسيا اتخذت عددا من
الاجراءات بهذا الشان تجاه الجانب
الاوكراني ومن جهتي لم يستبعد قائد قوه
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات في وزاره
الدفاع بيلاروسيا كاريل كزن سيف ان يكون
حادث سقوط الصاروخ الاوكراني التابع
لمنظومه 300 على اراضيها استفزازا من
القوات الوكاليه واوضح كزن سيف في تصريح
صحفيه ان الوزاره تدرس فرضيتين احداهما
اطلاق غير مقصودا اللي صاروخ موجه مضاد
للطائرات بسبب سوء ادري بالطاقم او خلل في
الصاروخ الفرضيه الثانيه سترجح ان ما حدث
هو عمل استفزازي متعمد من طرف القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه